in the meantime let's get more on that
report into who knew what and when about
doping in athletics joining us is sports
journalist Natasha Henry hello to
Natasha so on the surface it looked as
though it was looking to be pretty bad
news for a lord coe but we're hearing
from dick pound who see what a chair and
he's saying that lord coe's best place
to lead the idol AF out of these
difficulties what's your take on this i
agree with mr. pounds i think Seb Coe
has a reputation as someone who adores
athletics he's given his life to
athletics and I think he as much as the
fans of the sport want to see it clean I
want to see it competitive and want to
get some dignity back into the sport but
the question mark remains does it not as
to how much he may or may not have known
he told our own pool kelso just
yesterday that he knew nothing about the
doping but we've also heard from the
committee who are suggesting that it is
implausible that the idol AF committee
did not know about doping and bongs not
only in Russia but other countries too I
mean it's similar to what we've seen
sorry in football we've set Blatter and
there's always going to be questions if
someone's part of an organization and
then it turns out they're doing illegal
activities I mean we cannot say one
hundred percent whether he knew or not I
do think he needs to come out and give a
full and frank statement about what he
knew what he didn't know and what he
plans to do to make I've let it's clean
again okay so what do we know at this
stage what is crystal clear is that
Russians were doping and that some
people within the idol AF high up in the
iwf were taking money taking bribes to
keep that quiet yes I mean it's it's an
awful story and people commit their
lives to train in they give up their
family time their education and it's
it's not like football where they're
earn lots of money so to know that
you've been competing against people who
have been cheating effectively must be
really devastating
indeed so but you know the water reports
saying that the IWF Leadership Council
could not have been unaware of doping
and rule breaking so why then well let's
just listen to what dick parent has said
in in support of Zeb cone will come back
to you many of the the representations
the Commission has received on behalf of
the iwf have attempted to distance the
conduct investigated from the iwf itself
the Commission has been troubled by the
apparent unwillingness of the IWF to
acknowledge that the conduct does indeed
reflect on the i ee f and that it must
assume its responsibilities for what
went wrong it was also apparent to the
commission that the institutional
knowledge of the problems with russia
was far wider than has been acknowledged
and that the IWF had displayed no
genuine appetite to deal with the
problems enormous amount of reputational
recovery to be done but dick pond thinks
that Seb Coe is the right person to do
that my goodness me he has a hill to
climb there yeah I think what we need to
remember is Seb Coe is not to blame for
the current situation there's there's
several people who need to take
responsibility and that's anyone who is
involved at a management level in the
organization but I do think that he has
just come into the job we need to give
him the opportunity to right the wrongs
that have gone on in the past I don't
think there's any benefit to saken him
now to then employ someone else it's
more than likely going to be someone
else who was already part of the
organization and then we'll be having
this same conversation again okay could
you talk to you thanks for joining us